I got my hands on 18 in of Venom so
let's open it I'm going to give this
away on Twitch as well so stay tuned for
that okay this is the Box Inside the Box
lovely we have one of the prettiest
steel books I think I have ever seen
this is such gorgeous art such a cool
pose beautiful code for the game and of
course our beautiful Venom statue oh
boy he is big and here is the statue
this particular Spider-Man is really
cool because it looks like it's FL on
web and you've got miles over here love
it it is very large and very nicely
sculpted and also really light because
it's made of plastic rather than like a
poly Stone it's not really a statue it's
more of a very large figure but they've
done a great job the paint job looks
sick look at it such a menacing face
it's somehow even bigger than I expected
I know that doesn't make sense cuz they
adverti it everywhere but it's just it's
huge oh he's beefy